hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the WR Chess Masters
2023 sorry about calling it VR Chess
Masters I have no idea why I do this uh
but it's Levon Aryan versus yanip Yan
will play his wheelchair championship
against dingler and very very soon and
uh it's uh very nice to see
um uh if he's informed and he if he's uh
well just playing good games he always
or is he preparing and saving his main
preparation for the actual world
championship match and in the previous
video you've seen what Lavon can do
you've seen what he did to Magnus
Carlsen and that was six years ago and
you will uh see that he still plays the
incredible incredible attacking chess
and that his games are always the uh
there to be Marvel that so let's check
it out Levon with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 we
have Pawn to see for E6 Knight to F3 and
D5 nipple goes for the Queen's Gambit
declined at night the C3 and Bishop to
E7 with Bishop to F4 Bishop to G5 is
still the more more popular idea but
Bishop to F4 I believe is the more
modern approach uh we have castles E3
and now Pawn to C5 uh challenging the
White Center with d captures and C5
Bishop captures and C captures on D5 we
have Knight captures Knight captures e
captures and Bishop to D3 so the main
line of the Harvard's attack uh nothing
new new here both of them know this very
well we have Bishop to B for check by
nepo and now Knight to D2 King to F1 and
King D2 are also very much playable
moves here and they have been played
before uh level one prefers 90 and
Knight to D2 with Knight to C6 and now
uh Levon castles with Bishop to E7 by
nepo the bishop is no longer useful in
this diagonal uh and now there are a
couple of games that reach this position
eighth reason or move a rook to C1 and
normal Queen B3 and one move uh but here
uh sorry Knight the B3 unknown move but
here we have Queen to B3 and it is now
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game so let's see what nipple had in
mind here Bishop to F6 uh we have A3 and
now Queen to E7
uh we have Rook 8 to C1 uh preparing to
double up on the C file and the bush of
the E6 of course nipple also wants to
put his Rooks on the C file we have
Queen to B5 you don't want to see a move
like D4 on the board so Queen to B5 we
have Rook 8 to C8 and now Rook the C2 we
have font A6 challenging the queen and
now Queen to B6 and now nepo just goes
Queen to D7 he needs to free up the this
Dagon for the bishop to kick away uh the
the White Queen uh we have Knight the B3
and now comes Bishop to d8 and here uh
something really weird happened during
the game and notice that this is the
first time that nipple plays Bishop to
d8 so he attacks lavon's queen queen
back to C5 with Bishop to E7 between the
B6 and now he repeats Bishop to d8
notice that this is the second time
Bishop to d8 appears on the board uh
Queen to C5 Bishop to E7 again attacking
the queen and queen to B6 and here Lavon
plays Queen to B6 he paused the clock
and he called The Arbiter he wanted to
to claim a threefold repetition but as
uh Bishop to d8 only happened uh twice
and this is the the moment where we
started repeating moves uh and then here
Nepal has to play Bishop to d8 in order
for it to be threefold repetition so it
wasn't threefold repetition and nipple
was not interested in a draw and that's
why he played Pawn to G5 and okay you
can't be very happy when you see a move
like this especially when you're playing
against someone like nepo uh but okay
Bishop to G3 uh Bishop to d8 it's
interesting how uh nipple declines the
the the the repetition but he plays uh
uh the repetition uh just enough times
for it not to be a repetition of moose
and then he throws in another move and
now he repeats it Queen to C5 Bishop to
E7 Queen B6 and now F5 uh preparing Pawn
to F4 so Pawn to F3 a freeing up the F2
Square for the bishop you could also
play Pawn to F4 uh Levon prefer spawn to
F3 Bishop to d8 again nipple goes for
the sort of repetition Queen to C5
Bishop D7 Queen to B6 Bishop to d8 Queen
to C5 and only Now Pawn to F4 uh this
way uh probably uh nipple uh it gets
closer to move 40 so uh yeah he wants to
reach time control he wants to be
granted additional time but also
sometimes players will just do this they
repeat moves without actually having any
sort of uh hopes or ideas of repeating
the position sort of a you know just to
get into your head it's sort of like a
like like a Russian School of Chess
thing so e characters and F4 G captures
an F4 Bishop to F2 and now again Bishop
to E7 Queen to B6 and Bishop to d8
nipple just um Towing towing with uh
Levon here Queen to C5 and now Bishop to
F6 it's not that black is better here
he's just being weird uh we have Rook F
to C1 now the one finally triples up on
the C file and queen to G7
now you have to be very very careful
careful here as the queen now occupies
the semi-open G file Queen to D6 opening
up the the C file for the Rooks also
putting pressure on the bishop Here and
Now Rook C the EA taking care of both
threads now the bishop is nicely
defended and you can move your knight so
you don't have to worry about Rook
captures on C8 and here there are many
moves uh Levon could go for him for
example Bishop captures on A6 is one of
them because if uh Pawn recaptures then
the C6 Knight will hang but then you
have to worry about the ideas like
Bishop E5 then the queen moves then you
play Rook to C8 now uh this is actually
a thread because the Knight will be
defended and once you move the bishop
then even ideas like Bishop captures and
B2 so you you grab a pawn but you also
will have to give back the pawn so
instead Rook the E1 again goes after the
bishop and here nepo plays Knight to E5
puts pressure on the bishop on D3 and
there are many moves you could play here
but probably best for Levon
uh would be to go King to H1 because now
uh let's say Knight captures on D3 Rook
captures an E6 Knight captures an F2
with check Rook captures and now Bishop
captures on B2 okay it's it's a nice
position let's say queen captures on D5
threatens some very nasty Discovery skin
th8 you can trade a pair of Rooks Here
and Now Rook to F1 stopping any Rook D1
ideas and it's equal material uh
playable for both sides black is a
little bit better uh because the
position is
um more active and it's it's a bishop
against a knight plus the the two
against one and the queen side so black
is a little bit better but nothing too
spectacular however in the game after
Knight to the E5 uh Levon played Knights
the D4 which uh really uh complicates
um uh things and he really wanted to
catch an apple of guard but here nepo
shows just how well prepared he is and
how he's ready to take on dink for the
title of world champion so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out the game the only winning idea for
nipple in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to H3 that's right that's the move and
in order to spot this move you really
have to figure out uh everything that
that's happening here which is always
the case when you play against Levon
arunan the idea of Bishop to H3 comes to
mind once you ask yourself what happens
if I play Knight to F7 and the attack
the White Queen so once you ask yourself
this then you realize what lavon's idea
was all along levon's plan was to give
up the queen that's what he wanted to do
and now after Rook captures and Knight
captures on E6 the rook and queen are
attacked so Queen to H6 you're gonna
pick up the other Rook as well and after
Queen captures now you have two Rooks
for a queen you also have The Bishop's
pair and this is objectively winning for
white because uh well the blacking is
just white in the open Rook pair plus
Bishop pair there's just no defending
this so one way to do this is let's say
Rook to C7 and that's pretty much it
there's not much you can try here Bishop
to C5 is coming if you try some like
Queen B8 then even Bishop the B6 if you
go back with with Queen to f8 then even
Pawn to B for now this will be a nice
Outpost for the bishop if Bishop to d8
uh Bishop to C5 if Queen to H6 now you
just play Rook to E8 with check and
that's it King G7 Rook captures the
Knight is pinned
um uh he instant resigns for for black
and this is only one of the reasons that
uh one of the possibilities that could
happen so this is what Lavon had in mind
after Knight to D4 but the dent nipple
check Knight to F7 like we've just did
here and he played Bishop the H3 and now
uh Checkmate is being threatened and now
uh Knight to F7 is a grave threat
because there's only one good way to to
stop this bishop to F1 this stops
checkmate but now look at this Knight to
F7 attacks the queen and how do you
reply to this the Knight on D4 is
hanging it's attacked twice by the queen
and by the bishop so you have to play uh
Queen captures on D5 or queen captures
on F4
uh to defend the Knight on D4 but it
doesn't help you uh because one of the
Defenders is the bishop on F2 and next
move also Rook captures on E1 is
happening so that's uh that's the
unfortunate thing here for Lavon there
is one thing you could try Knight the E6
but let's not forget about our good
friend the bishop on H3 uh also helping
with the defense of the uh the uh E6
Square so there's really not not much
point in doing that so here are queen
captures on D5 was played now Rook
captures on E1 and now Bishop captures
on E1 Bishop captures on D4 with check
King to H1 and now Bishop back to C8 and
now after all is said and done nipple is
just up a full piece as you can see both
players have a queen rook and Bishop
pair but nipple also has a knight so uh
unless Levon is ready to beat nepo being
a piece down uh this is a now completely
winning for for Nepal so Bishop to c411
of course will try everything uh he did
go into this round as the leader of the
tournament and he would very much like
not to lose the game but it's just too
much material rookie goes after the
bishop Bishop to B4 and here we have
Queen to F6 we have Bishop to D3 uh
nipples King is still wide in the open
so perhaps it's possible to to attack
the king but it's not going to be easy
because here the move that nipple plays
is absolutely spectacular and that is
Bishop to C3 uh mind-blowing move uh
blocks The Bishop's defense of the E1
Square now you're threatening Rook to E1
Checkmate and there's no good way at the
capture because uh you either allows on
captures or or you allow Checkmate so
here he did Play Bishop captures on C3
but now nipple just plays Queen captures
on C3 removes the defender of the E1
Square once again so you cannot capture
because well like we said if you capture
is just a check Bishop covers and
Checkmate so here G4 was played uh by
labone but now just Queen back to F6
you've eliminated even more material
from the board so now being up at night
is even more spectacular Rook the C7 was
played uh trying to pile up on that
night but it's nothing really Rook D1
with check with King to G2 Bishop to E6
now we have Queen to H5 going after that
H7 Pawn but now just Queen capture some
B2 with check King H3 Levon putting
everything up for this one attack but
they just Pawn to H6 that stops the
attack king a queen to G6 now not moving
the king but actually Queen to G7 even
though you could play King to f8 it's
still perfectly winning for black uh we
have King to H4 and now Rook the H1 and
he was in this position that uh Levon
had enough and also it was in this
position that level and arunian resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh one way the game could
continue is okay you have to either push
H3 or defend the pawn but it doesn't
really matter you can just trade here
and you are very happy with the same
game Knight G5 checklist the king G2
Rook to D1 and uh there's no defense
Rook to D2 checkfall by Knight captures
and F3 are coming and they're just is no
good way to stop this you can very
easily pile up on that pawn and if you
try something like H4 like we said Rook
to D2 check into F1 Knight captures on
F3 eliminates the pawn and now the king
is completely paralyzed here on the F1
Square rook and I doing good work here
and next you will see Bishop captures
and Bishop to H3 and this will be
checkmates only one of the ways this
could continue but there's no point in
continuing because Lavon knows that
nipple will definitely find all of this
so truly a remarkable game and it's uh
it's really wild that Levon tried to
call the uh the Arbiter to rule a
three-fold repetition but it wasn't
because Bishop to d8 only happened twice
and then he played after this Knight E5
move he played this Knight the D4 which
is just absolutely spectacular for first
for Nepal to find Bishop to H3 and then
I mean once you see it of course it it
all makes sense but first the the actual
is spot this you have to try what
happens after Knight to F7 once you see
Knight to F7 doesn't work and this is
exactly what Lavon wanted you to play
then you find the bishop to H3 and
that's exactly what happened in the game
so maybe Levon uh just thought that this
was his tournament everything was going
his way and he was going to you know
crush the World Chess Championship
challenge or yeah and okay it's
different to uh maybe I shouldn't call
him Roger Championship Challenger as
he's not challenging the world champion
he will only play the World Chess
Championship match against England uh
but yeah he he thought that he he will
win this one and that it's going to be a
great day for him unfortunately that's
not what happens he still remains in the
lead of the tournament
corrupted him but it could still be a a
a great tournament for him this is only
one one uh you know uh uh well a hiccup
along the way uh so yeah that's the game
I hope you guys enjoyed it uh really
awesome stuff by Yan we'll see how he he
continues the tournament and of course
we are all very much looking forward to
his match against dingler and I would
like to thank Joyce Roseman Bernice Dean
and Nadine Walton Gordon Hatfield and
Claude Huber for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out the
previous video If you haven't it's
really a wild one see you soon